what's going on you sexy pieces of huh
yeah make sure you guys stay tuned at
the end of this video because you know
but Ryan's gonna hook it up with one of
these beats Oh what's going on you too
so if you guys noticed last week I did
this sketch with belaga ladies Cassie
how lovely lovely lady now a lot of you
guys have been asking how I develop a
lot of these sketches and what's kind of
like the brainstorm that I go behind it
so when I started doing funny fat fit it
turns out that a lot of people's
motivations were different for losing
weight now whether it was for health
reasons or vanity it doesn't really
matter all I cared about was getting to
that goal that you want in a healthy
manner now when I was doing funny fat
bit it turns out that a big portion of
the message that I got weren't actually
from the people that wanted to lose
weight it was from the wives that one of
the guys to lose weight but usually what
happens when somebody asks you to lose
weight versus you wanting to do it
yourself you get pissed off ostrich egg
she told me yesterday don't stand on the
ostrich shell I said to I said because
what can come off as honey I'm worried
about your health can come off as you
were so sad but in reality what she's
saying is you look like you're gonna die
and a lot of the times would you find
out is that when it comes to these
couple situations there's a lot of
communication breakdown because there's
one person that means something and
there's the other person that takes it
the wrong way for your help you mean you
didn't calm us down have a fat-free
snicker something wrong now one of the
things that I love doing when I shoot
this videos is directing directing is
actually one of my huge passions now
cassie has never acted in anything
before in her life now pending that she
did an amazing amazing job the funny
thing was when we were trying to get
casted to act in this her she had to be
angry here's the thing
cassie is not an angry person she is by
far one of the sweetest most nicest
people on earth and so we asked her to
be angry this is her reaction
[Music]
now of course in most of my videos the
majority of cameos did you see is from
Khalif Boyd and even he had a little
trouble doing his lines because we
actually had to shoot this around 2 a.m.
in the morning yes it was tiring to tell
but you didn't turn out as bad as I
thought you were oh [ __ ]
all right I'm not gonna say I'm pretend
that you're perfectly fine pretend that
you're perfectly fine but I Oh what is
going on you two hope you guys enjoyed
that beets yes it kind of the background
story to that but once again thank you
guys and also thank you Verizon for
hooking it up and making this video
possible
and on top of that for hooking one of my
subscribers up with one of these bad
boys so if you guys don't know what
these headphones are these are beats
solo2 x' dos now for me when I travel I
always travel with these headphones why
because number one I like the fact that
it goes over the ears really comfortably
and on top of that even though it's not
sound deadening it actually does a
pretty good job of it and on top of that
when I get a phone call I could be like
this what's up who there who there oh
cool thing about this - look at this pop
snap back bumpity boobity bop bop bop
compact so if you guys want to go ahead
and cop one of these make sure that you
go down into the description box below
and click that bit link for me make sure
please click it for man and of course
make sure you go ahead and check out
www.vitac.com as well so how do you guys
win one of these u.s. what I want you to
do is click the bit link tweet this
video hashtag the dating game
hashtag David so comedy and I will pick
a random winner to win one of these last
week somebody want a Samsung gear s that
man was named Jonathan [ __ ] Shi H
Jonathan [ __ ] he cocked himself a
Samsung gear s
and you my friends will be happy one of
these so once again
hashtag Davis oh comedy hashtag the
dating game tweet this video and click
that bit link and bang bang boom you
will cut one of these cuz febris all
loves you
David still loves ya and beverage down
favorites out there but I loves ya there
at all nothing